Kylie Jenner changed my life I saw her
in the cover of Forbes and I was like
she's younger than I am and she's a
billionaire and I feel like I know more
about business I have a fundamental
belief that if someone makes more money
than me or better at business me in some
way and I need to learn from that I will
study everyone anyone who's making more
money than me I'll study when I saw that
it was such a paradigm shift for me I
was like how is this possible I was
taking between 13 and 17 million a year
personally I thought I was doing pretty
well then I saw that and I just felt
horrible about myself it like ruined
like a week of my life and then after
that Conor McGregor boom he was at 600
with proper 12 and then the rock came
out with terminal he's at two to four
billion depending on who you're looking
at and it just happened again and again
and again and I was like I'm missing
something here I believe that the only
thing that you would need to grow a
business was paid ads and outbound for
me to be a billionaire I didn't
understand Brandt and it was my big
deficiency and when I saw each of those
I was like oh I have to get into this
and I started making YouTube videos
shortly thereafter that was kind of the
beginning of me starting to post